AND HIT EIGHTH SEASON HE THIS S.
OUT.
>> IBUT LET'S SEE.
>> AFTER REVIEW THERE WAS WAS
GOALTENDER INTHE RIGHT CIRCLE ST
BLOCK IN FRONT OF THE NE ABLE TD
JUST. BROWN
WRAPAROUND OFF THE GOALPOST TO
THE OTHER SCORE
SEVEN AND GET TT
BACK THAT'S THE W RAYMOND.
HIM.
>> DO YOU MAKE THAT MOVE TO THE
BLUE LINE AND THEN SWITCH GEARS
AND GET A STICK T
THE GOAL, TWO
SPECIAL TEAM NOW AFTER HE JUST .
PUCK,HROUGH AND
JOSEPH IS ON THE SPOT.
YOU DON'T ATTACK THE GOALTENDER
ON T THE TIME.
>> O YES.
>> IT WORKED OUT
HERE IS EXECUTION BY CIDER KEEPT
IN SHOOTS AND HE SCORES.
MATTHEW.
SIX
YESGHT BE BACK.
>> I DON'T KNOW. RAYMOND GOES
DOWN INTO THIS AREA DIDN'T HIT
SOME AWAY, EMPTY
NET AND THEY SCORE.